يناشد دولة عربية ورسميا طباخ
بوتين يرفض اوامر وزارة الدفاع
الروسية. فكيف سيرد بوتين
والتنين الصيني ينفث لهيبه نحو
كوريا وبكين تتجسس على الولايات
المتحدة منذ مدة طويلة وتايوان
تستعد للحرب بطريقتها الخاصة.
واليابان تعلن مواجهة صواريخ كم
والسعودية تقول كلمتها لتضرب
بصوت عقابها الالمان والامريكان
واليابانيين معا في السودان تحطم
الامل مجددا. والاسرائيليون
يتعرضون لحادثة مؤلمة اخرى على
الحدود المصرية. رد روسي صاعق.
ضجيج محركات الناتو لا يكفيه
توسع الحلف باتجاه روسيا وضع
الزيت بجانب النار ليذهب اعضاء
الناتو نحو اللهيب الروسي
بالمنفاذ. وبعد ايام من تصريح
الامين العام السابق للناتو
اندريه فو جراس موس حين قال ان
بعض الدول الاعضاء في الحلف قد
ترسل قوات الى اوكرانيا بشكل
فردي. جاء الرد الروسي بتساؤل من
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ديمتري ميدفيديف عما اذا كان
سيؤخذ برأي سكان هذه الدول في
مثل تلك الخطوة قائلا. حسنا هل
سألت سكان هذه البلدان? من منهم
يريد الحرب مع روسيا? هل يريدون
حقا ضربات تفوق سرعة الصوت على
اوروبا? وغير بعيد عن مهاترات
الناتو مع روسيا تواصل اوكرانيا
هجومها المضاد. وهنا اعلن وزارة
الدفاع الروسية احباط محاولة
اوكرانية لاستهداف سفينة تابعة
لاسطول البحر الاسود وتدمير جميع
الزوارق الستة التي شاركت في
العملية. بينما اعلنت القوات
الروسية عن صد جميع الهجمات
المضادة الاوكرانية على محوري
خلال الاربع والعشرين الساعة
الماضية. وتدمير ثلاث دبابات
الايوباد ونظام دفاع جوي بريطاني
من نوع ستورمر. وكرد على الدفاع
الروسي جاء الدور على الاوكران.
حيث اعلنت كييف ان قواتها احرزت
تقدما لعدد من المواقع بالقرب من
مدينة باخمود شرق البلاد ونجحت
في التقدم الى ما يصل الى الف
واربعمائة متر في عدة مواقع من
الجبهة. لافتة الى انها كبدت
القوات الروسية خسائر فادحة
ودمرت معدات عسكرية في المنطقة.
نحن لا نأتي بشيء من مخيلتنا.
المصدر. في القيادة العسكرية
الشرقية قال ان قواته تحاول شن
ضربات على العدو وقد نجحت في
التقدم بما يصل الى الف
واربعمائة متر في عدة مواقع من
الجبهة لافتا الى انها كبدت
القوات الروسية خسائر فادحة
ودمرت معدات عسكرية في المنطقة.
لتضيف انها استعادت بلدة بلاجو
ديتني الواقعة شمالي باخموت
وانسحاب القوات الروسية منها.
لكن وبحسب التقارير الغربية فهذه
التقدمات الاوكرانية ليست مجدية
مقارنة بالدعم الغربي الضخم.
فكيف حكومات الغرب ذلك. تاتي
الاجابة من صحيفة نيويورك تايمز
حيث اشارت الى ان الولايات
المتحدة واوروبا يعتقدون ان
الهجوم المضاد قد يصبح نقطة تحول
في النزاع ويعتمد الكثير على
النتيجة اي ان مستقبل اوكرانيا
مرهون بنجاح هذا الهجوم. فما عدا
الغرب يطيق تكلفة الحرب الباهظة
عليهم. وعلى ذات السياق عرض قائد
القوات المشتركة في الجيش
الاوكراني سلاحا مضادا للطائرات
يطلق عليه فيكتور. وقال ان معدل
اطلاق فيكتور حوالي ستمائة طلقة
في الدقيقة ويضرب الاهداف الجوية
على مسافات طويلة بشكل موثوق.
كما ان السلاح سهل الصيانة
ويمكنه المناورة ومن السهل
اخفاؤه في موقع اطلاق النار. من
جهتها عادت الدفاع الروسية لتعلن
ان قوات كييف تكبدت نحو سبعمائة
عسكري وعدة اربع منها من طراز
الالمانية ورتلين من المدرعات
وكالعادة اليكم المصدر. القوات
الروسية قامت باخماد هذه
المحاولة واه اعادة الاعداء الى
الخلف مع الحاق اضرار جسيمة
بالافراد والعتاد من بين اه
العتاد العسكري اه اه مدرعات
امريكية واه اه دبابات ليبارد
ايضا على محور اه اه محور
اوجلدار كان هناك قتال عنيف وآآ
قصف المدفعية. فيما دوت صافرة
الانذار معلنة حالة التأهب
لغارات جوية في العاصمة كييف
وجميع المقاطعات والمدن
الاوكرانية. هناك ناشد الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي وزيرة التغير
المناخي والبيئة الاماراتية مريم
المهيري التي تزور كييف حاليا
لدعم صيغة السلام التي تروج لها
كييف. ليعلن الرئيس الشيشاني
رمضان قديروف عن تحرك عسكري
لقواته وذلك بتشكيل فوجين جديدين
من وزارة الدفاع احمد روسيا
واحمد الشيشان من مقاتلين ذوي
خبرة والذين سيذهبون قريبا الى
منطقة العملية العسكرية الخاصة
في اوكرانيا وفق قوله. ومن
اوكرانيا الى روسيا وبعد ان امر
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شايغول
جميع وحدات المتطوعين بتوقيع مع
وزارته بحلول نهاية الشهر وهي
خطوة قال انها ستزيد من فعالية
الجيش الروسي ليرد قائد مجموعة
فاغنر العسكرية بقوله ان مقاتليه
لن يوقعوا اي عقد مع شويجا رافضا
بذلك اي محاولة لوزارة الدفاع
لاخضاع قواته لسيطرة الوزارة.
وبالعودة الى قضية تفجير سد
كاخوجا. قالت المتحدثة باسم
قيادة عمليات الجنوب الاوكراني
ان تفجير السد ادى الى غمر حقول
الالغام وجميع التحصينات التي
اقامتها القوات الروسية عند
الخطوط الامامية للضفة اليسرى من
نار دينيبرو في خرسون مؤكدة
تراجع قوات موسكو نحو خمسة عشر
كيلومتر. بكين تكشر عن انيابها.
بالقلم والمسطرة يتقدم الصينيون
بخطوات هندسية معتمدين على
الفيزيائية كالعادة فلكل فعل ردة
فعل. وهنا استدعت بكين سفير
كوريا الجنوبية لدى بكين شونج
جايون وقدمت له احتجاجا شديد
اللهجة ردا على استدعاء سيؤول
للمبعوث الصيني لديها نهاية
الاسبوع الماضي. وعلى الطرف
الاخر قالت ادارة بايدن ان الصين
تتجسس على الولايات المتحدة من
قاعدة في كوبا وذلك من قبل تولي
بايدن للرئاسة. ولكن واشنطن
العمل لتعطيل خطوات بكين في
كوبا. فجهود التجسس الصيني مصدر
قلق مستمر للولايات المتحدة. اما
في تايبي فاجرت القوات المسلحة
التايوانية تدريبات عسكرية بحرية
في ظل تصاعد التوترات مع الصين.
حيث تمت محاكاة ازمة رهائن في
مدينة في الجنوب فهل ترى تايوان
ان جنودها سيكونون رهائنة في حال
اندلاع الغزو الصيني? هل هناك
اخذ رهائن لدى اصحاب العيون
الضيقة. الاحداث والتطورات. مددت
وزارة الدفاع اليابانية الى اجل
غير مسمى امرا بتدمير صواريخ
كورية شمالية او شبايا لها حال
وجود تهديد بالسقوط على اراضي
البلاد. فرضت التجارة السعودية
غرامات مالية على عشر وكالات
سيارات المانية وامريكية
ويابانية وصينية خالف نظام
الوكالات ولائحته التنفيذية.
ومنها وكالة المانية لم توفر
قطعة غيار بمواصفات فنية خاصة
خلال المهلة المحددة. شن الجيش
السوداني هجوما واسعا على جميع
جبهات القتال وقام بغارات جوية
مكثفة على مواقع للدعم السريع في
مدن العاصمة الخرطوم. ليفيق
السودانيون صباح اليوم التالي
لانتهاء الهدنة على اصوات
الانفجارات والمدافع والرشاشات
محيط مدينة الفتيحاب جنوبي ام
درمان. بعد حادثة الجندي المصري
ثم سرقة السلاح والذخيرة اعلنت
تل ابيب انقلاب حافلة في صحراء
النقب كانت تقل تسعة عشر جنديا
اسرائيليا اصيبوا بجراح مختلفة
والبعض منهم في حالة خطرة. روسيا
تطلق تهديدا صريحا للناتو برأيكم
هل يريد الحلف حقا رؤية ضربات
بصواريخ موسكو الفرت صوتية.